et françois souvent si en direct donc
sur rt france soit choquant si bonjour
vous êtes général de brigade et expert
en géostratégie merci d'être en direct
avec nous ce matin une parade des
militaires aériennes réduite un public
absent pour raison de crise sanitaire
quelle est l'importance symbolique de ce
défilé du 14 juillet pour le corps
militaire qui finalement cette année et
voilà est en comité restreint place de
la concorde
je crois qu'il faut rétablir sa dans son
contexte
d'abord le 14 juillet est une fête
nationale à laquelle les armées sont
forcément partie prenante mais pas
qu'elle d'ailleurs le thème du 14
juillet est très claire aujourd'hui 1
c'est uni solidaire
donc je crois que c'est important le
deuxième point aussi qu'est ce que le 14
juillet le 14 juillet ce n'est pas lé la
démolition de la bastille où la prise de
la bastille
c'est surtout 1790 et non pas 1789 c'est
à dire la fête de la fédération
la fête de l'unité nationale c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui quand on voit des
manifestations dans paris que sera la
cgt où les gilets jaunes on peut
s'étonner qu'on oublie que le 14 juillet
c'est la fête de l'unité nationale et
qu'on doit laisser de côté toutes ses
revendications au moins pour la journée
et puis maintenant pour les armées ce
qui est important c'est de bien montrer
que la zone est présent dans la crise
pas forcément d'une manière énorme
compte tenu de nos moyens mais on était
là on a montré que l'état était là par
ses armées et les armées ont largement
contribué au début de la crise a été
notamment les soignants à faire face à
cette crise
justement vous parlez du rôle de l'armée
l'armée qui a donc participé à cette
lutte contre le corner virus avec
l'opération résilience en mettant
notamment à disposition des avions en
transportant des soignants en formant
des hôpitaux de
uniterre également est ce le rôle de
l'armée justement en temps de crise
sanitaire d'être présente
alors je dirais qu'en tour de crise en
général
l'armée reste pour moi au moins il faut
beaucoup de militaires le dernier
recours de la nation pour faire face à
n'importe quelle crise les militaires
sont disponibles 24 heures sur 24 n'ont
pas de droit de retrait ne cherche le
réclame pas ne sont jamais en grève et
sont toujours disponibles
c'est la négation c'est le service de la
patrie quelle que soit la crise
maintenant sur le coville nous avons des
moyens nous avons montré que nous
pouvions aider l'état à faire face les
hôpitaux en particulier et nous avons
des moyens avec le service de santé des
armées qui est aujourd'hui mis aussi en
valeur
plus de dix mille militaires de la
direction de centrale du service des
armées ont été utilisés nous avons huit
hôpitaux d'instruction et nous avons
plus de 2000 médecins
on ne peut pas négliger cette force
supplémentaire pour faire face à une
crise telle que l'unc au vide alors la
patrouille de france 1 est en train de
survoler la place de la concorde pour la
fin de l'hommage au général charles de
gaulle puisque cette année voilà on
célèbre un triple anniversaire trois
tableaux ont été présentés qui retrace
les moments forts de la vie du général
général qui marquera qui a marqué la
france à tout jamais on le voit encore
avec emmanuel macron qui a voulu rendre
hommage aujourd'hui tout à fait je crois
qu'il faut bien réfléchir à qui était
charles de gaulle
charles gaulle et finalement à nos
fichiers presque comme les autres saint
cyrien engagés dans la guerre de 14 18 a
été fait prisonnier après a servi en
pologne
justement pour participer à pau réveil
de la pologne
ensuite surtout il a été reconnu
identifié par le pouvoir politique comme
étant quelqu'un qui avait des idées car
il a écrit entre les deux guerres et
c'est surtout le symbole de la
résistance le symbole du refus de la
défaite
le symbole de celui qui veut la victoire
même s'il est tout seul et finalement
même les gens de gauche qui l'ont
beaucoup décrié quand il était au
pouvoir
commençons par mitterrand jusqu'à
l'extrême droite aujourd'hui marine le
pen
les politiques aujourd'hui se réfère
tout ça de bol pourquoi parce que de
gaulle était à des réfugiés qui avait un
sens politique mais un sens politique et
qui permettait aussi de d'abord mettre
la france d'abord et les parties ensuite
et c'est pour ça que nous avons une
constitution qui sapent celle de la vème
république qui fait de la france qui
donne à la france à un régime
présidentiel avec un président de la
république est aussi chef des armées
doué emmanuel macron aujourd'hui chef
des armées réel pas uniquement pour
simplement pour le montrer et il est
vraiment chef des armées et c'est de
gaulle qui a mis ça en place car il sait
que la france a besoin de gouverner il
sait que la france a besoin d'avoir un
régime fort avec un exécutif puissant
même si d aucuns le regretterai et
finalement quel que soit le parti
politique sans doute à part extrême
gauche disent bien que charles de gaulle
est un exemple par cet anneau fichiers
et un officier montre l'exemple
c'est ce qu'a fait de boules justement
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
emmanuel m'apprend on va essayer de
montrer l'exemple pour c'est que le chef
de l'état va s'exprimer à la télévision
la traditionnelle interview du 14
juillet pourtant ils l'avaient voilà
annulées auparavant et l'a finalement
pour pour cette édition 2020 il va se
prêter au jeu
oui mais je crois que personnellement
j'estime que c'est bien en tant qu' un
chef
un exemple impressionnant république en
période de crise doit montrer qu'il est
là il doit répondre aux attentes des
citoyens
le 14 juillet fête de l'unité nationale
dont j'ai parlé tout à l'heure qui est
quand même là où théoriquement on met
dehors tous et tous ces a priori pas on
va écouter le président de la république
qui va apporter des messages qui va
donner des informations
alors effectivement aujourd'hui ça ne
sera pas un exercice convenu comme avant
et on peut comprendre la critique de
générer de ce 14 juillet où chaque
maison de république qui aimante parler
pour ne rien dire
là comment pourrions-nous comprendre
qu'un président de la république en
temps de crise sociale économique
éventuellement pandémie ne puisse pas
s'exprimer et ne s'exprime pas devant la
nation et finalement le 14 juillet est
la meilleure date possible
aucun plaisir d'un public s'exprime
alors le chef de l'état qui a également
prononcé un discours hier devant les
armes et voilà que les a remerciés on
sait que pouvait l'espérer 2020 n'a pas
toujours été facile pour eux est ce que
c'est important aujourd'hui pour le
président justement d'être aux côtés de
son harnais de leur montrer voilà qu'ils
s'inquiètent également de leur moral oui
tout à fait le 14 juillet
traditionnellement est aussi sinon
devenu la journée des armées où on
montre l'armée française où elle défile
au oui mais ce n'est pas le défilé qui
est important c'est qu'elle est mise à
l'honneur
quand je disais il ya quelques instants
le président macron et chef des armées
il est responsable aussi de la condition
militaire du moral des armées surtout
que comme je l'étais aussi tout à
l'heure les militaires ne disent rien et
pis je trouve des solutions sans
contester il a des hommes et des femmes
qui s'engagent pour la france et qui
font passer leurs presque un intérêt
particulier bien nous de là bien après
l'intérêt général l'intérêt général
prime et je crois que le prénom de ma
chrome contenu de ses débuts difficiles
en 2017
avec le départ du général de villiers
qui a été comme une affaire
malencontreuse
et pas très pas très correct 1 le
général de villiers a quand même fait ce
qu'il fallait pour les armées pour
qu'elle fonctionne quand il était aux
affaires
et que cette crise certes temporaire à
imposer au président de la république
année après année on le constate depuis
2010 est à prendre l'armé en
considération à respecter des hommes et
les femmes qui la respectent respecter
ses chefs et s'est sans doute rendu
compte que quand ils demandaient quelque
chose lessard mais faisait elle ne
disait rien il s'agissait et je crois
que dans une société qui est toujours en
train de de regimber sinon de nous dire
ah ben non je ne ferai pas de sujet
penderie c'est bien pour un pigeon d'un
public d'avoir une institution sur
laquelle pouvoir compter merci beaucoup
françois chossy d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
général de brigade et expert en
géostratégie